Youngstown Ohio der König der make
America great-bewegung nutzt die
bevorstehenden mit terms um mit seinen
Lügen Stimmung zu machen
die Wahlen wurden manipuliert und
gestohlen nun wird unser Land zerstört
nach Trumps Rede salutiert die Menge mit
der Geste von
Q9
immer offener umarmt Trump all jene die
an eine Verschwörung in Amerika glauben
doch Trump ist damit keine Ausnahme
sondern setzt eine jahrzehntelange
Tradition seiner Partei fort
das belegt jetzt der Journalist David
corn mit seiner Recherche
American psychosis eine historische
Spurensuche wie die republikanische
Partei wahnsinnig geworden ist so der
Titel
mein Buch legt innerhalb eines Zeitraums
von 70 Jahren das offen was man als
dunkle Seite der republikanischen Partei
bezeichnen kann also wie die Partei
Fanatismus und Extremismus von
Rechtsaußen befördert hat also
verschwörungsmythen Rassismus Paranoia
Fanatismus Tribalismus und damit alles
was ich unter Extremismus verstehe
6 Januar 2021 befeuert von Trumps Lüge
einer gestohlenen Wahl stürmt ein Mob
das Kapitol eine bewusste Strategie
Trumps stellt später der
Untersuchungsausschuss fest Höhepunkt
einer Entwicklung die in den 1940er
Jahren beginnt die new deal-politik des
Demokraten Franklin D rosewelt drängt
die Republikaner ins Abseits
Republikaner Joe McCarthy sorgt 1950 mit
angeblichen Enthüllungen einer
kommunistischen Verschwörung für Panik
die Regierung sei von sowjetagenten
unterwandert Verteidigungsminister
berühmt für den Marshallplan deren
Anführer
es war vollkommen irre und irrational
und immer geht es um den inneren Feind
das sagt im übrigen auch quranon dass es
eine Elite gibt die den Plan hat Amerika
zu zerstören und eine Diktatur von innen
heraus zu errichten im Kern geht es um
dasselbe
1964 erhebt re:publikaner Barry
goldwater dieses Denken zur parteiraison
für seine Präsidentschaftskandidatur
sucht er bei einer einflussreichen
Lobbygruppe Unterstützung in der sich
Antisemiten Rassisten und
verschwörungsgläubige vernetzen
deren Gründer Robert Welsh behauptet
dass die gesamte Regierung in
kommunistischer Hand sei und einem
Masterplan von geheimgruppen wie den
Illuminaten Folge doch dieser Irrsinn
hält goldwater nicht davon ab 10.000
Mitglieder der Berge Society für seinen
Wahlkampf zu nutzen und den Extremismus
offiziell zu adeln
[Musik]
[Applaus]
zwar verliert goldwater die Wahl doch
die extremen Ränder gehören seitdem zur
republikanischen Basis
[Applaus]
in ihrer gesamten Geschichte hat die
republikanische Partei das Sony
anerkannt sondern von sich gewesen wie
den verrückten Onkel den man auf dem
Dachboden versteckt
Republikaner die man vielleicht für
vernünftig und gemäßigt halten würde
befeuerten zwar nicht explizit
Extremismus aber sie nutzten diesen
dennoch um Wähler zu gewinnen
an George age Double You Bush erinnert
sich die Nation heute als gemäßigten
Republikaner
1988 tritt er im
Präsidentschaftswahlkampf parteiintern
gegen den Evangelikalen Pat Robertson an
der tv-prediger unterliegt doch seine
Anhänger organisieren sich fortan in der
Partei
1991 bringt Robertson seine Weltsicht in
Buchform Freimaurer
Illuminaten Kommunisten und jüdische
Banker würden im Auftrag Satans die Welt
in eine Diktatur verwandeln doch trotz
dieses Extremismus sucht Busch den
Schulterschluss mit ihm ein Millionen
angelikaler Wähler kommt kein
Republikaner vorbei
George
Bush geht also zu Pet robertsons
jährlicher Konferenz seiner christlichen
Lobbygruppe und bezeichnet ihn als
großen spirituellen Führer hier haben
wir das Beispiel eines relativ
vernünftigen Republikaners der dennoch
Pet Robertson anerkennt und seiner
Gefolgschaft vermittelt dass sie auf ihn
hören soll und dass dieser einen legitim
Platz in der amerikanischen Politik hat
Obamas Präsidentschaftskandidatur 2008
löst bei den Republikanern einen
extremistischen Schub aus Obama als
Feind Amerikas zur verteufeln darauf
zählen John McCain und Sarah paylen in
ihrer Kampagne ab Jan McCain
Obama sei mit Terroristen befreundet und
zu riskant für Amerikas oder Sport
gemeint ist die lose Verbindung Obamas
to Bill Ayers Gründer der links
militantengruppe weather Underground
später behauptet paylan das Obama mit
seiner Gesundheitspolitik Todes Signale
für Senioren einführen wolle
innerhalb kurzer Zeit glauben ihr 30%
der Amerikaner
McCain und paylan geben den
irrationalsten Instinkten ihrer Wähler
Futter schreibt kaum
das verschwörungsmotiv war schon immer
ein Schlüsselelement der
republikanischen Partei und ihrer Basis
und genau dieser Aspekt bekommt immer
mehr Bedeutung von pailen über die
Tea-Party bis hin zu Trump er wird immer
wichtiger weil er von top-republikanern
befeuert wird
mit Trump bekennt sich die Partei heute
offen zum Extremismus gerade hat er
angekündigt dass er sehr sehr
wahrscheinlich 2024 erneut als Präsident
antrete an ihm kommt heute kein
Republikaner mehr vorbei die Basis steht
hinter ihm
61% der Republikaner und mehr als die
Hälfte der republikanischen Kandidaten
der mit terms Folgen trumpslüge einer
gestohlenen Wahl torpedieren damit
Grundwerte der Demokratie
[Musik]
wenn die Republikaner das
Repräsentantenhaus oder den Senat
gewinnen dann wird die Lehre daraus sein
dass sie Gewalt anstiften und
rechtfertigen können die verrücktesten
verschwörungsmythen verbreiten und sogar
versuchen können Wahlen zu kippen und
wissen Sie was Sie bleiben trotzdem an
der Macht
wäre die Grand all Party ein Patient
dann wäre eine Therapie derzeit sinnlos
noch sind die Gewinne der amerikanischen
Psychose für die Republikaner zu groß
und die Bereitschaft der Partei zu
gering sich selbst zu ändern doch das
ist Voraussetzung für jede Form der
Heilung